uh my question is how do you reconcile
the history of the church and their
Traditions with the actual word of God
how do you know what the word of God is
without
tradition that's a good question exactly
because you haven't thought about it
you're just repeating typical Protestant
propaganda so you said word of God
right and you're referring to the Bible
right yes sir how do you know those
books are the word of God who told you
uh well I only really did a little bit
of research on where the King James
version comes from but I even questioned
the books in the King James like because
I have
into yeah you're your own authority
notice you see what you just said I even
questioned the books in the King James
so you become your own Pope and
Authority so my question is by what
right do you have to question
anything what I'm saying you're not a
prophet right no and you're not an
apostle right no
okay so by what Authority do you have to
question the context of the Bible and
number two how do you know what the
Bible is apart from
tradition well I guess I I I don't yeah
exactly so when you talk about tradition
the Bible you have is a tradition
because tradition means to pass on and
to receive go look at the origin of the
word tradition it means to pass on to
receive
your Bible is a tradition that was
passed on to you so you need to then
look at history to see where the Bible
came from and whom God used to gather
these books and tell you these are the
books of God no more no
less and when you do that okay very men
the very men that God used to give you
the Bible who are the very men who
taught things that you think are not
biblical such as intercession of saints
Mary's Purity Perpetual virginity in
they taught all of these things so if
you were to look at that church that God
used to tell you this is the Bible and
God used to preserve the Bible they
didn't teach your
protestantism okay so when I said I
questioned the books I'm not questioning
like I guess it was more of like why did
they take out because I did a little bit
of research on the set Tu aent and how
they had some of Apocrypha books in
there so when I said I question is like
why did they take those out who took
them
out uh I'm I believe I could be wrong it
was the Church of England okay so that's
the Protestant churches that's my point
yeah you you your history or the history
of the Protestants goes only to the 16th
century 16th century is where
protestantism starts so people like
Martin Luther and John Kelvin decided
that they would become their own
authority determining what tradition to
accept what tradition to reject and what
books to accept what books to reject so
this is the fruit of protestantism what
do I mean everyone thinks that he or she
is qualified enough to tell you what the
Bible means and to tell you which part
of church history to accept and
reject this is the problem but if you go
beyond and you go to the church before
the reformation and you start writing
the writings of the second fourth
century Christians their writings are
still preserved when you start reading
what these men believe about the Bible
and about the church you're going to see
that what you now hold to in
protestantism it is so
far a drift and different from what
these Christians believe this is why a
lot of protest
stop yeah because I I've been listening
to a lot of your a lot of your teachings
on the Eastern Orthodox church or this
Orthodoxy and Catholicism as a whole um
because I I you made a very good point
when you said that the Protestants
always teach that Catholicism is uh
paganism because uh they use the word
they say that you guys worship Mary uh
but I understand it's
veneration um so and I I I bought a lot
of books because you uh I believe you
recommended getting the catechisms of
the Catholic Church
[Music]
I hear something in the background like
some noise in the background I don't
know what it is from your end might my
computer's fan maybe okay now let let me
show you the difference between because
you'll have people like Jamila white
telling you oh and the Protestants with
solar scriptor tot script we have more
agreement than Catholics and Orthodox
that's not true because I'm gonna show
you Eastern here you have Eastern
Orthodox listening you have Catholics
listening look at the comment section
I'm going to ask a series of questions
look Oriental Orthodox Oriental Orthodox
Eastern
Orthodox Catholics and Assyrian Church
they're here okay now watch Eastern
Orthodox Oriental Orthodox Catholics
Assyrian church do you all believe in
infant baptism watch watch the comments
okay do you all believe in infant
baptism I want you to see how much
agreement they have and they don't
follow so scripture look see do you all
believe watch here do you all believe in
water baptismal regeneration that the
spirit uses water baptism to regenerate
you make you alive unite you to Christ
you all believe in water baptismal
regeneration watch look watch the
agreement without solar scriptura aian
Church Catholic Oriental EAS they're in
Schism by the way okay do you all
believe the Eucharist by the grace of
God's spirit the Eucharist by the grace
of God's spirit when the priest who's
authorized by Christ prays becomes the
Flesh and the blood of Christ the Flesh
and the blood of Christ listen
watch watch just look at the coms don't
look at me look at see these are
Catholics Assyrian church or inter
Orthodox e they're not in agreement some
condemn the others as Heretics all right
it's okay do you all believe do you all
believe praying for the dead in Christ
those who've died in Christ you all
believe praying for them you all
believe I want you to see I'm wrong with
this
watch see are you seeing the
s's okay do you all believe intercession
of saints that the Saints are alive
perfected and pray for believers on
Earth watch here almost done because I'm
going to then turn on protestantism
watch here do you see that all
right do you all believe in Mary's
Perpetual virginity she remained the
Virgin and that these brothers of Christ
are not children of Mary they're either
cousins or children of
Joseph see see that watch there's a
16-second delay so just wait because I
want you to see I'm gonna ask then I'm
going to show you the fruit of
protestantism watch here okay do you all
believe that the the Lord kept Mary pure
out of his grace and mercy and
love
buter see
that
now hear
noise let me put my headphones on real
quick yeah put your headphones on okay
now I'm gonna show you protestantism
young man so it seems like you're open
may God bring you to the full like he
did me now watch
you go to a Protestant ask test me on
this you saw the agreement right they
don't follow Sol script
topt ask a Lutheran when you find the
Lutheran independent fundamental
Baptist reform
Baptist all right hopefully it get
better I'mma mute
myself okay now only unmute when you
answer now find an independent
fundamental Baptist
okay find an independent fundamental
Baptist you listening just no your yet
if you're
listening okay find a reform Baptist
reform
Presbyterian Lutheran you can write
these down F or you go back and relisten
to this part
Lutheran
Anglican Church of Christ these six
groups independent fundamental
Baptist re reform
Baptist right reform Baptist okay good
I'm a missionary baptist I want you to
hear
Lutheran
Lutheran Anglican that's
Episcopalian okay Presbyterian Church of
Christ these six groups ask
them what do you believe about
baptism they don't agree they'll tell
you it's symbolic or that baptism will
make you spiritual alive regenerate you
Lutheran Church of Christ anglicans
believe water baptism is used to
regenerate you make you
alive
okay independent fundamental Baptist
Reformed Baptist Presbyterians say no
ask them do you believe in infant
baptism lutherans Presbyterians angli
anglicans yes Church of Christ
independent fundamental Baptist and
Reformed Baptist no okay is the
Eucharist the flesh and blood of Christ
Lutheran anglicans
yes Lutheran called it consubstantiation
consubstantiation Presbyterians reformed
Baptists Church of Christ Independent
vental Baptist
no they can't even agree on the basics
let alone the issue of predestination
and whether Christ died for everyone if
you ask to form Baptist who's a
fivepoint Baptist or Presbyterian who
follows tulip Christ only died for the
elect and if you ask him can you lose
Salvation Church of Christ yes anglicans
yes right reform Baptists no if you're
truly elect you'll endure and remain
till the end and aend the Baptist
no this is the fruit of just
six of the many Protestant denominations
all claiming Sol scriptura to scriptura
yet I just told you Eastern Orthodox
Oriental Orthodox Assyrian Church
Catholics whether Eastern right
Byzantine right Latin right all of them
without solos scriptor all agree on
those
doctrines so if you're in protestantism
you're going to be confused because
you're going to hear one Protestant tell
you water baptism regenerates you makes
you alive the other said no it doesn't
it's symbolic but if I say Eastern
Orthodox Oriental Orthodox Catholic
Assyrian water baptism regenerates you
amen if I ask Lutheran and Presbyterian
Eucharist flesh and blood of Christ
Lutheran yes Presbyterian no Baptist no
Eastern cathol Eastern Catholic or
Eastern Orthodox Oriental Orthodox C
Catholic Church Ser church is it the
flesh and blood of Christ yes and on and
on it goes
so the more you study the ancient church
and the more you see what the Christians
believe for the first 300 years say I
try to see what the Christians taught
for the first 300 years because sadly in
the 400s they started splitting there
was schisms in the four fifth century
400s but I try to see what the
Christians of the first 300 years
believe and you know what you're going
to find buddy you're going to find Mary
was kept pure Mary a perpetual virgin
Eucharist is the flesh and blood of
Christ an office of priesthood prayers
for the dead intercession of saints
water baptismal regeneration and infant
baptism and they didn't have internet
they didn't have social media they
didn't even have contact with many
churches because they're spread all over
the world and yet they all came to the
same conclusions because that tells you
these teachings must have come from the
apostles passed on to their successors
who then spread over the world and pass
them on it's time for you to go look
into the ancient church and see what
they T because that's the church that
God used the church didn't create the
Bible no Catholic Orthodox says the
church created the Bible if they know
their faith they'll say the church was
used by the Holy Spirit to know what the
Bible is and to canonize it because
before Luther before Calvin these
Christians way back then were the ones
given the
scriptures we're the ones in trust with
the scriptures so the spirit moved these
Christians to know what the scriptures
are to copy them preserve them explain
them and die for
them so you can't tell me hey uh this
tradition contradicts the word of God
when the word of God came to you as a
tradition someone gave it to you that's
what a tradition is pass on receive
someone to say wait how do you know
that's the word of God why do you think
I know that heretic who said oh Christ
won't return
physically I go where'd you get that
from he goes show me the word of God I
go how do you know the word of God is oh
I believe it I don't care what you
believe the Muslims leave the crime
because I was going to use the early
church that gave him the Bible because
that church said Christ will be return
physically and bod to judge the living
and the dead which he
denies so it's time for you to now
continue read the catechism look to
these churches forget about
protestantism brother